whoa whoa colors that's good
[Music]
adjustability pivoting
whoa how's it going jig pretty good I am
just getting fraps going on my computer
so I can record this for you guys
something we've been talking about for a
while around here is Sam Gorski comm
America needs
America wants America must have a home
page that home page is Sam Gorski calm
not only am I going to build it without
him knowing and then show it to them
later on I'm also going to show you guys
just a little bit about how easy it is
to build pretty much any website you
won't find over the last four years I
spent a lot of time building the
corridor digital comm website so I've
learned that I cut right to the chase
use Squarespace if you're going to do an
online store the next best place to
start is Shopify obviously you're more
than welcome to go out and Google tell
your heart's content
what other platforms there are but those
two you're going to get the job done
quickly and for relatively low price
hashtag not spawn look you get john
malkovich using Squarespace you've got
to know that it's legit the first step
to designing a website using Squarespace
is to pick your template template
actually is really good this is the elk
template start with this design boom
what kind of website is this is it
professional services or is it
photography let's call it personality
bio what do we want to do with this
website and we want to get hired awesome
it's just a bunch of BS next your site
title and torski
: America's home page now Griffith has
this awesome plug-and-play
style editor that you can just kind of
adjust fonts and colors and themes and
margins if you know a little bit more
and you want to make your website a
little bit more tailored it also allows
you to go in and on the back end and put
in your own code yourself so it's able
to allow anyone to use it from a
beginner to an advanced designer my
favorite tattoo my favorite tattoo is
probably this Eagle done really well big
and bold
and it's kind of like my style you know
if you're going to go go for it also it
reminds me to you know be free like a
bird so why do I ride a Harley oh wow I
mean the first thing that you're going
to hear when you ask anyone why they
ride a Harley is freedom and the second
thing that you're going to hear is
freedom on your face you know because
when you ride in the wind hitting you
and you're just cruising right along I
mean really kind of a kind of a
phenomenon that most non Harley riders
don't really get yeah you sure you got
the cafe racers out there you got the
sport bikes you got custom bikes but
there's something work people really
come together when they ride when they
ride Harley Davidson and you know the
thing and that I think makes all that
possible is steel and fire fun fact
so actually not only do I have a tattoo
not only have my ears been pierced I
have a brand out of this competition and
basically ended up with me getting
branded by an ESCO they asked took one
on backwards it was f4 shipstead which
was my dorm he said when he pulled it
away it was like string cheese like
melted cheese from a pizza it remains
pain for about ten seconds the nut rest
in peace mr. mushrooms also do the nurse
started
[Music]
my dad
the first step to designing the first
step to designing a website using square
[Music]
UI
turns out Ren's expectations were
surpassed